on this Friday night the risky military
mission inside Canada's care homes more
soldiers contract copa 19 concerns about
compensation and proper training for
troops breaking news on the federal wage
subsidy Canada's big three political
parties are the newest applicants deadly
disaster a plane plummets from the sky
and into a neighborhood plus fresh fight
for freedom why activists fear Beijing's
new bombshell spells the end of Hong
Kong
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
Robyn Gill good evening and thank you
for joining us as provinces slowly
reopened across the country the need for
testing and contact tracing will be
critical today Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau announced his government will
fund provincial efforts to test people
for kovat 19 and tracked the contacts of
those who test positive federal contact
tracers will have the capacity to make
thousands of calls a day when provinces
asked Ottawa is also helping to procure
swabs and other key testing materials
that will be needed taking strong
collaborative action to expand testing
and contact tracing is important for
both Canadians and businesses to have
confidence that we're on the right foot
they need to know that we have a
coordinated approach to gradually reopen
that is rooted in science evidence and
the ability to rapidly detect and
control any future outbreaks testing is
still lagging in many provinces
especially those hit hardest by the
virus Ontario's testing is only at half
of its daily capacity despite a spike in
case numbers today that province
reported 441 new cases and 28 more
deaths the highest daily increase in two
weeks what's more troubling Ontario
hasn't been able to account for the
source of exposure for more than
two-thirds of reported cases in the past
month
Quebec remains the epicenter of Canada's
outbreak and the province has yet to
achieve its testing goal today 646 new
cases and 65 new deaths were recorded
but Quebec is allowing some cultural
activities to restart at the end of the
month museums libraries and drive-in
theaters will reopen May 29th Quebec and
Ontario have been getting help from the
military for the past month more than
1,700 troops are assisting in long-term
care homes hit hard by the pandemic but
the number of soldiers getting sick is
also climbing and fast soldiers aren't
currently getting hazard pay
but as Abigail Beeman reports that could
change
most kovat 19 deaths in Canada have
happened inside long-term care homes and
there's been a sharp spike in the number
of cases acquired by the soldiers who
have gone inside 29 cases Friday up from
five last week the Department of
National Defense tells Global News the
spike is in part due to a wait for
formal confirmation of test results the
forces must be transparent with the
numbers veteran and advocate Silva
Chartres has been tracking troops
working in long-term care homes I've got
information that the training was really
rushed for the typical soldier that's
concerning DND won't provide details on
the 29 people who got sick but says no
one needed hospitalization Chartrand is
calling for soldiers to be protected
from health concerns that may arise in
the future and right now while they're
on the frontlines he's pushing for
danger pay he has the support of
opposition parties I am very confident
they're gonna reach the right decision
on this yes they could do it quicker as
soon as our troops started to become
infected with covet 19 it was inherent
upon the government to and put in place
the hazard pay and benefits and so for
them to not to react and and do that now
is a failure Global News asked the prime
minister why hazard pay is not yet in
place and these are discussions that are
ongoing within the military while he
wouldn't commit to anything Friday
afternoon the chief of the Defence Staff
announced he's asked staff to pursue
hazard pay for those inside long-term
care homes and promised more information
soon the military is now waiting to see
if provinces will extend their requests
for help Quebec's agreement lasts until
June 12th Ontario's just until Wednesday
that province tells Global News they're
looking at all options abigail Beeman
Global News Ottawa a vaccine using
technology from Canada and China appears
to be showing promising results in
humans a report published today in The
Lancet medical journal shows some of the
participants developed antibodies and
t-cell responses against the virus
month after vaccination a hundred and
eight adults in Wuhan China are taking
part in the study they were given a
single dose of a weekend common cold
virus called adenovirus most
participants reported fever or fatigue
which is typical for vaccines but there
were no serious side-effects further
trials are needed to confirm if the
vaccine will protect people from cope at
19 this is one of about a dozen covin 19
vaccines in the early stages of testing
as Ottawa rolls out financial aid for
Canadians we're learning tonight some
federal parties are getting in on it too
both the liberals and conservatives are
receiving the 75% wage subsidy benefit
and the NDP and Greens have applied for
it political donations have been drying
up during the pandemic the subsidy is
aimed at helping businesses keep people
on the payroll and rehire laid off
workers so far the government has paid
out 5.7 billion dollars through the
program we're getting a look at the
effect of the pandemic on retail sales
in Canada
according to statistics Canada retail
sales in March fell 10 percent to 47
point 1 billion dollars the biggest
plunge on record clothing and
accessories stores were the hardest hit
with sales dropping more than 51 percent
and gas station sales plunged more than
19 percent it's estimated about 40
percent of retailers closed their doors
during the month on the other hand food
and beverage stores saw sales jump more
than 22 percent in the US president
Trump has deemed all churches and other
houses of worship essential and he's
demanding states across the country
allow them to reopen this weekend
the governor's need to do the right
thing and allow these very important
essential places of faith to open right
now for this weekend if they don't do it
I will override the governor's it's
Memorial Day weekend in the US which
marks the unofficial start of summer
south of the border
normally millions of Americans travel
for the holiday but health officials are
warning them to stay home and keep their
distance as Jennifer Johnson explains
there
concern the long weekend will cause an
uptick in cases as Americans head out to
celebrate this Memorial Day weekend
after like sixty something days indoors
it's nice to soak up the Sun warnings
from nervous state leaders we expect
people to be getting out going to parks
peaches etc but we have to remain
vigilant at the same time New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo trying to avoid a
new nightmare emerging virus hotspots
popping up in states that quickly
reopened like Texas Florida and Alabama
the virus is not gone the virus is still
out there this is a smart virus that
spreads very easily from person to
person not every coastal town is
welcoming holiday travelers including
parts of the normally packed Jersey
Shore the most important months for this
town for our businesses for the
municipality are the months of July and
August and that's why it's so important
that we get this right the first time
the US Travel Association predicts many
Americans will stay home spending 4.2
billion dollars this Memorial Day
weekend a third of what was spent in
2019 for the first time in 20 years
triple-a is not releasing the Memorial
Day travel forecast
US President Donald Trump is creating
controversy with his own holiday travel
plans a visit Monday to Fort McHenry in
Baltimore the place that inspired the
national anthem the mayor has asked the
President to reconsider set an example
and not come to a city still under a
stay-at-home order Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington
CSIS and the FBI are warning about the
growing threat of hackers targeting
researchers working on Cova 19
treatments Canada spy agency doesn't
point the finger at China but the
Federal Bureau does accusing the
communist government of trying to steal
intellectual property today the Prime
Minister was asked what Canada is doing
to protect Cova 19 research from theft
by hostile States Justin Trudeau also
didn't mention China we have long been
concerned about intellectual property
protections in Canada that's why we've
increased the funding for the CSC which
is a communication security
establishment that watches over
cyberattacks and make sure that our our
systems are safe
Trudeau did say he's alarmed by China's
move to impose a new national security
law on Hong Kong the proposed
legislation could result in a crackdown
on pro-democracy groups and reduced the
territory's autonomy there have been
countless anti-government demonstrations
in Hong Kong focused on the Chinese
government's increasing control more
than 300,000 Canadians live in Hong Kong
and as Eric Sorenson reports they along
with the rest of the world are watching
what happens next
it is China's major political gathering
of the year and the National People's
Congress has moved swiftly to propose a
law to assert Beijing's security control
over Hong Kong once and for all
fine don't run gong Shirdi citing
interference by foreign hostile forces
the Congress vice chair said powerful
measures must be taken the measures
would give China's government the power
to directly enforce security in Hong
Kong a small protest by pro-democracy
activists took to the streets and some
lawmakers scuffled with security in Hong
Kong's legislature under the British
handover in 1997 a one country two
systems' agreement ensured hong kong
some autonomy till 2047 TTP is burning
Hong Kong activists say Hong Kong's
freedoms will be lost so they are
announcing to the world that Hong Kong
is no longer under one country to system
it is now one country one system Hong
Kong stock market fell more than 5% on
Friday
internationally Canada's prime minister
who has sharpened his tone with China
over two Canadians being held by Beijing
has now joined the UK and Australia
expressing deep concerns over Hong Kong
we have 300,000 Canadians who live in
Hong Kong and that's one of the reasons
why we want to ensure that the one
country two systems approach continues
for Hong Kong Justin Trudeau did not
address possible sanctions u.s.
president Donald Trump suggested he's
prepared to act if the laws change in
Hong Kong masks on all but the most
senior officials are a sign of the
extraordinary times for Beijing facing
global criticism
over the corona virus and now Hong Kong
but seems prepared to weather both put
up with the types of opposition that
you've been seeing seeing in Hong Kong
and that it is prepared to respond very
decisive activists are promising larger
protests but it's unclear whether Hong
Kong's future will be one more dynamic
altered during the Cova 19 pandemic Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto a
catastrophic plane crash in Pakistan
coming up the neighborhood that turned
into a disaster zone plus a Koba 19
hotspot no more how one Canadian city is
defeating the virus
captain Richard MacDougall seemed to be
in good spirits in his first public
appearance since the crash involving a
snowbirds plane McDougal the pilot is
recovering in a BC Hospital on Sunday he
and his teammate captain gen Casey
ejected from their tutor jet she did not
survive the military is now
investigating in Pakistan a jetliner
carrying 98 people crashed in a crowded
neighborhood of Karachi at least 80
people are dead
the plane was experiencing engine
trouble trying to land and as crystal
commencing reports the crash comes just
days after domestic flights resumed
sirens horns and desperate voices echoed
off the concrete where an airbus a320
crashed moments after a distress call
take flights from the hotel karachi
karachi to sama
it could be anyone ask any one of us on
any given day and i think t know that it
could have been you or it could have
been somebody you know in that plane who
doesn't come back home Uther Ascari
captured images from the scene Friday
afternoon she's a local journalist and
knew a few of the passengers on board
domestic flights just resumed this week
as lockdown restrictions were eased
hospitals declared an emergency citywide
this system already struggling with
kovat 19 patients officials warned it
will take time to identify all of the
victims but there are a few survivors
this is said to be the president of the
Bank of Punjab being rescued a scorer
says somehow he ended up on top of a car
there was a family inside that moment
just replayed in my head again and again
just how one person can be ever so lucky
the Prime Minister has committed to an
inquiry Airbus says it will provide
assistance with the investigation
the CEO of the national airline
acknowledged the head pilot radioed that
he had mechanical trouble he called the
crash an extremely heart-wrenching
incident one that has robbed people here
of the joy of Eid which marks the end of
Ramadan crystal commencing Global News
London still ahead a former neighbor of
the Nova Scotia gunman says police
ignored her warnings years ago Global
News has uncovered disturbing details
about the man who killed 22 people last
month in Nova Scotia a former neighbor
Brenda forms claims she moved away from
porta pick after the gunman started
stalking her and she says she tried in
vain to get authorities to investigate
the killers weapons and evidence that he
was abusing his common-law partner
Ross lured reports when a gunman
murdered 22 people in Nova Scotia before
police killed him Brenda Forbes felt a
different anguish than most I thought to
myself nobody listened to be everybody
protected him Forbes says years earlier
she reported Gabriel wormans growing
weapons collection and evidence he
emotionally and physically abused his
common-law partner she come over crying
saying that Gabriel was beating her up
and wouldn't let her leave Forbes says
in 2013 three men saw the gunman choking
that same partner one of the witnesses
the gunman's uncle Glenn Wortman has
confirmed that assault two Global News
and I called the RCMP and I told them
what happened she says she went to the
gunman's uncle Glen to see if he'd give
a statement to police he said no way
because Gabriel's already told me that
he's killed somebody in the United
States he'll kill me if I say anything
the Mounties have said they're
investigating one american angle how the
gunmen acquired some of his illegal
weapons from the u.s. asked if they're
investigating any connection to possible
murders there a spokesperson says
members are investigating every possible
investigative avenue but the RCMP says
it's fine
contain no record of any complaint from
Forbes she says she met with an RCMP
investigator this week and he says just
to let you know your story is totally
believable not good enough at the time
as the professional denturist acquired
illegal weapons and decommissioned RCMP
vehicles like the one police say he used
to deceive unsuspecting victims before
he killed them he had white privilege he
had power and that he had money and we
have to treat everyone equally and start
looking at the behaviors of the person
advocates say the issue of male violence
against women needs to be included in
any public enquiry they note RCMP
statements that the killings started
after the gunmen assaulted and confined
his partner who escaped Forbes says in
recent weeks people from the port 'epic
area have phoned her saying they're
sorry for downplaying her courageous
efforts Ross Lord Global News
Halifax a community crushes the curve up
next the success story in Brooks Alberta
Calgary and Brooks Alberta have been
given the green light to start easing
restrictions the two cities have
experienced the highest levels of Cova
19 infections in the province today
Alberta's premier confirmed the number
of cases is declining enough to allow
both communities to open more businesses
Hair Styling and barber shops will be
permitted to reopen in Calgary and
Brooks cafes restaurants and pubs and
bars can also reopen for table service
at 50% capacity this upcoming Monday and
on June 1st day camps including summer
school will be permitted with limits on
occupancy in those communities the
outbreak in Brooks was one of the
largest in the country more than a
thousand cases and seven deaths most
infections were connected to a meat
processing plant the premier says the
outbreak is largely contained and 99% of
infected employees have recovered
heather York's West looks at the massive
community response that helped the city
get to this point Romulan bi is hoping
to go back to work at the jbs
meatpacking plant in Brookes next week
she's been off for a month taking leave
at first because her son's daycare was
closed she had no idea she had also
contracted kovat 19 actually I don't
have any idea when or where I got
passeth Eve
the virus began spreading through the
small Alberta City in mid-april there
were outbreaks in multiple locations
including the meatpacking plant dozens
of new cases were being reported each
day because there's no cure there's no
treatment there's there's no vaccine
clearly so we testing is really the only
way to understand what's happening in
your community with it and so we pressed
really hard for the first asymptomatic
test site beginning on April 27 the
testing event was held for anyone in
Brookes whether they had symptoms or not
3650 three people were tested over three
days ten percent of them were positive B
I was one of them so I went there in the
same days after that they called me a
day after that I've got positive noes
hand comes at all that kind of strikes
you that 10% of your asymptomatic
population is testing positive it I
think it allowed everybody to understand
oh wait there's a bigger problem here
part of that problem Brooks is a
community of many hard-working people
from all over the world many have
multiple jobs living in crowded
multi-generational homes we actually
decided to call in outreach to everyone
in our database and that's about 1200 to
1300 flights muhammad idris is a part of
the community's Cova 19 Emergency
Operations Center he says cultural
support played a vital role in curbing
further spread educational material was
translated into 13 languages and people
who were unable to isolate at home were
put up in hotel rooms by the first week
of May the curve started to flatten and
people began to recover a little more
than two weeks after the outbreak speak
less than 100 active cases remained on
May 12th a second three-day testing
event was held this time 1663 residents
came out for testing and less than 1% of
the
or positive I do think this is a success
story I always say that everybody owns
public health and so a success success
on behalf of everybody be eyes son was
also tested for Kovan 19:00 fortunately
he was negative the is now considered
for covered the little family is looking
forward to resuming some kind of normal
after a chaotic few weeks this mom at
least won't soon forget
Heather Erik's West Global News Brooks
Alberta and that is global national for
this Friday I'm Robin Gill tonight your
Canada is this group of foxes playing in
Kingston Ontario we would love to see
your corner of this country so email
your pictures to viewers at global
national calm thank you for watching and
I'll see you back here in this weekend
have a great night
[Music]
you